[Music]
things get awkward for Camila Cabello on
The Voice as a contestant sings her
ex-boyfriend Shawn Mendes's song that's
a good way to look at it it all went
down during the blind auditions where
voice Contender Tanner Howe took the
stage to win over the coaches his song
Choice mercy
on me
yeah and right off the bat Camila
realizes The Familiar tune
don't even know your power
when I'm around
[Music]
I'm begging baby please have mercy on me
take it easy on my heart that song might
have hit a little too close to home for
Camila because she didn't turn her chair
for Tanner that was like it's Sean on
stage you sounded like yeah wow you know
he's best so that's awesome I know him
better than everybody in this room
but the reason I didn't turn around was
I felt like you sounded a little bit too
much like him obviously he has an
amazing voice I love this song but I
would be curious when you pick your
coach for you to just kind of
distinguish yourself well seems like
there isn't any bad blood between Sean
and Camila post breakup I think we're
really supportive of each other when the
two announced their split last November
they shared in a statement that they
began their relationship as best friends
and will continue to be just that I
really think when you know you know and
um she's been one of my best friends
since I was like 15 years old which is
why it's no surprise Camila couldn't
help but crack a joke about it on the
voice I was in his Lane deeply hey
all right now she said it we heard it
she's trying to make it as awkward as
possible
it's so fun I have so much fun with
these guys I get excited and giddy when
I see you guys it's like going to school
and seeing your funny friends
clowns well despite the Havana singer
not turning for Tanner her fellow
coaches did but the 29 year old
ultimately picked his fellow Orange
County native Gwen
mostly baby
[Applause]
I won I beat Jon and I beat Blake
[Music]